hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play pong the real
slender game actually they're changing
the name to just slender haunt or haunt
slender or hunt some or just haunt I
have no idea but they're changing it in
the upcoming release um this is a
slightly updated version they made
Slendy just a bit more aggressive so I'm
gonna get in here and I'm gonna play it
on paranormal because I'm a fool to
myself and then hi slender I grow extra
photos game starts at night oh I didn't
I didn't know that it was I didn't know
that it was daytime when I started
before either way okay
I'm gonna be playing on paranoia because
I want to get into the action and figure
it out as soon as I can what would you
do if you will get in a place where he's
never been through fear no and now since
this is my second time playing this
someone said you could change the
intensity of your flashlight with the
scroll wheel pretty intense okay so
anyway I'm just gonna get hurry the hell
up and grab everything in that akin I
know pretty much where I'm gonna be
going see nothing there nothing there
nothing there here we go apparently that
scared people every time I flip that up
the last time so I'll be sure to
remember that at random points
throughout the game that won't be a
jackass about it but we will be going
into here sorry you can't see oh I
remember that
okay I'm gonna head to the house first
get the keys get deaf F out of there and
then move on my merry way wherever the
hell I am kind of forgotten okay
don't need to waste battery because I am
playing on paranormal ergo it will be
much more difficult
wait where's the where mi thing where's
the where mi X oh don't tell me I'm
paranormal they don't give you a where a
my ex guy alright okay I'll deal with it
anyway hello is this where the house has
can't see anything
does it ever turn today oh here's the
house okay
so I'm gonna go in the house I'm gonna
get what I got in here all of its faulty
mechanics and all that see what was that
did I get the key in here I don't even
remember
oh yeah the cubes right on the steps
okay there's nothing else in the house I
got the lookout key I'm just gonna go
straight for the lookout tower they said
they're gonna fix that sound in the next
update too so hopefully y'all won't have
to deal with that at least I won't have
to deal with that you'll still have to
deal with that if you're playing the old
version but I won't good god no I like
it though it's growing on me okay so as
we venture out into the darkness we
search in our souls to find who we
really are what - hello what are you
what the hell is this oh it's batteries
never mind I'm an idiot something
paranormal happening yep I don't get in
I don't get a where am i thing but I'm
pretty sure that the lookout towers just
in the woods here at least I'm I think I
have no idea really I'm gonna hit the
lookout tower first because the lookout
target hahaha genius super genius
ultimate mega awesome super ultra genius
so turn mine oh god that was the
footsteps I was like what the hell was
that I can no let's keep that on just
real low I'm gonna try to be smart about
this playthrough I don't know if I'm
gonna go as long as I did before I have
a feeling that me playing on some
paranormal and then
them kind of dating the slender
mechanics to make a bit more aggressive
might mean that I may die sooner but I
still have a lot of praise for this game
and they mentioned I read that they said
that they're naming of haunt the real
sunder game was kind of pretentious they
didn't intend for this game to be
popular at all but I could tell that it
was gonna be so they're gonna change the
name because they didn't like the idea
of people thinking that they were
claiming slender's their own thing or
whatever people were saying I don't
really know I didn't care myself I just
liked the game okay come on we're the
top of this tower damn it okay finally
geez all right
whoa hello backdoor key to the house and
another photo foul scary huh look out -
backdoor
alright back down we go oho my favorite
tearing sound okay boom so I am assuming
that mr. mark slender he's gonna be
coming after me very soon why did I pick
paranormal I actually actually don't
know why I picked that considering that
they did update the game to make him a
bit more aggressive why didn't I just
pick gamer I'm an idiot I don't know I'm
gonna give this game another real long
thorough try after after 1.0 gets
released which is to which is set to be
released this Friday at some point in
time I have no idea one okay come on
come on there we go that's better
alright so the house should be just up
this way through the woods through the
Wimbley woods and slender burbled as he
came
doc get your mind out I got her okay yep
oh I was right on target on target okay
now I was assuming that there might be a
flashlight or batteries near the yeah
shut up
batteries near aha and isn't there a
picture on this truck maybe baby
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's too early
for that
get out here Slendy whoa back off man
you're getting all up in my grill I need
to at least get on one more photo all
right now you can kill me and made me
and dismember me I would I hope they
don't remove the horse doors the horse
doors at my favorite I like these doors
okay so I got that I got the photo here
now I can start moving up north to the
the the bunker thing the atmosphere this
game is stellar I mean a lot of you
people out there who might be
criticizing it for it doesn't seem like
it's not bad you got to play the game
and be right here with headphones on a
dark room and just kind of being alone
because when you're watching out there
you're not really alone you're safe in
the comments sections I'm not I have no
comments I have no people I'm all
recording this in the past for you
future people I have no idea I'm all
alone
okay the bunker oh hang on hungers gotta
be over in the woods this way I don't
think I've actually ventured into the
woods here I might as well give it a try
what was that I saw I saw something
glowing something white could have been
Slendy face or his nipples poking out of
the Mist
okay I might be getting myself a little
lost here which would probably be a big
mistake but I have a feeling that
there's something back here what is this
gram I did I hit another road I thought
I went straight due west and I didn't
think there would be anything out here
ah shut up man damn it's dark
my flashlight is at maximum intensity
and I'm wandering out into a field where
what the hell what the hell
what's this fence wait a minute how did
I do I can turn around somehow am I
headed east instead that would be
incredible but I don't know how that
would happen like seriously I don't know
how I would have gotten turned around
like that because this this these look
like woods that I wanted through before
but they were farther out eat oh I'm at
the haunted demon tree oh how did I get
here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah demon tree
demon tree give me your photo or page
gimme gimme gimme
I want it thank you
Wow get away get away get away get away
you know I'm not ready to die just yet
no no still got time still got time
hey back off I'm not gonna suicide on
you just yet okay so holy hell I don't
know where I am I keep getting turned
around because everything everything
looks like woods it's so strange that I
get lost in these woods that I am in ok
now I think Salone is decided to leave
me alone for the moment yeah how did I
scare you okay it is weird the way it
flashes up against a flashlight like
that where's that Clippy clop II got a
horse
screw you and the horse you rode in on
horse he rode on honey I'm falling this
road wherever it leads me I don't really
know
aha finally oh wait this doesn't help me
because I can't oh oh this might be to
the bunker
maybe maybe I'm wrong what is that I
wish those ah aha I was right this is
this is to the bunker okay okay
what do you [ __ ] yeah yeah man it's a
frickin bunker now I have suspicions
that there's a key in this bunker which
I may not have been able to see because
I had my flashlight way up way too high
which is blowing out everything in here
so I'm not gonna leave here until I find
said key
I mean seriously the deep I've
discovered that this game was made on
the Unity engine it's just really really
detailed and lots of like high quality
textures bump mapping all sorts of
technical whiz-bang Murray ah that's
funny
Velma drew a dick on the wall huh uh huh
now that's funny that's funny right
there okay okay I don't see anything
there's that way out there and this is
back worthy I know the page is down here
or the photo or whatever I'm gonna I
don't know I'll find it I'll find it
don't you worry guys I'll find it yep
yep yep yep yep maybe it's not here wait
what's up hey oh I got it I didn't see
it though okay I'm good I got the Wow
I've gotten more photos this time around
I think see if I go this way then I go
up north again if I can't find the key
here then I'll just hit the factory and
I'll be good
yeah my flashlight actually is at the
lowest intensity it just doesn't look
like it but uh bloom okay so no there's
got to be a reason why this is here and
this is opening you can come out here I
mean you can't get out of the area but
it's here so there must be something I'm
just gonna spend the uski as I walk
around because if I could find ah come
on
nothing really would there just be
nothing I don't understand why there
would just be nothing here huh I don't
know damn it
I could have sworn that like I would
have thought that they would definitely
have been a key in here somewhere and if
there is it's really well hidden among
the rocks okay I'm out of here I'm out
of here I am Wow
oh no no no not right now Slendy I don't
have an escape route route this isn't
the right exit not right now not right
now not right now thank you very much
okay I'm gonna
Olo all the lights seems to be burning
out to my flashlight up and venture
north I'm thinking ha damn it all of the
lights are busting okay so if I ventured
North I'll hit that factory that is a
factory not a power plant with aura
haunted bunny like I had suggested
before that is actually a factory and I
guess I'll keep going I'll keep going
until sundar gets me I thought he'd be
like a lot more aggressive than he has
been I mean he's been more up in my
grill than before I only got four pages
of nothing three notes four photos in
three notes so yeah I'm not really sure
I'll I'll figure out eventually I mean
he'll come get me no matter what but I
gotta get more stuff first now there was
the thing ah wait there was a thing in
the middle of this woods like the little
shack I found hey Wow holy balls get out
I can't sprint oh god oh god oh god oh
god don't kill me don't kill me
aha the shack the shack f off good god
okay so I am like I'm I don't know why
but I can't seem to sprint maybe that's
part of the paranormal mechanics oh come
on wait no there were multiple ones hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey back off can I
be left alone for two seconds please
and poof BAM like gone
sad do say okay
I'm just kind of wandering aimlessly now
there's no way I'll be able to find
these things about a better
understanding of the layout of the land
dammit
all right let me just keep heading north
I think I think this is north ooh hello
what are you I think there was something
up here batteries come on
sprint guy jeez paranormal must mean
that this guy turns into a giant [ __ ]
and can't run for two seconds and I
swear if I was being chased by slender I
would never not run seriously I am no
athlete but I'm pretty sure the
adrenaline and whatnot would get dia and
you'd run until you collapse
at least a slow jog not huh huh
walking apprehensively towards my doom
there we go here we go here we go here
we go this is it this is it visit got it
yes yes please now where this is in
relation to everything else I don't
quite remember ah why who's poking his
head up out of his little tree fort here
get out of my treehouse no girls allowed
but on the man no you're a giant [ __ ]
as my slender voice that's my slender
kid voice what was that oh god he's
gonna he's gonna come up suddenly I'm
gonna feel sharp thing poking me in the
back home it's gonna be cilenti's
nipples just right in the back okay so
anyway so I think if I turn right here I
will be able to escape go come on
okay
all right then um I guess that's it it
was quite a bit more aggressive I will
give him that then again I did know more
of where things were anyway
let's flip through some of these extra
here that's the factory that's the car
where you started my character has a
cowboy hat apparently um house with a
shadowy figure and a crowd that's ouch
wits or one of the concentration camps
and the rest is a mystery okay so that
has been my second try of haunt the real
son or game I will give this this game
another thorough try come Friday or this
weekend whenever the new one is released
I will try it again
see what's new and what is in store for
me so thank you again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye-bye
hey don't don't even think about it